[Musique]
nathalie golfe bonjour ce carmouze
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
parce que quand on se retrouve c'est
qu'il ya envies de lecture donc on va
proposer beaucoup de livres à nos
téléspectateurs grâce à deux
intervenants njawe un scan mécanique
bonjour bonjour vous êtes libre est vous
êtes libre et demi le livre bleu à
versailles et vous allez nous parler de
deux livres sur les ossements des morts
de le gars tôt car c'est comme ça intel
et frinault balkans même de littérature
donc je voudrais quand même à rien
prononcer et puis entre fauves deux
autres fours de colonial et puis ya
christophe maury qui est avec nous aussi
qui est écrivain
bonjour ce qui est neuf bonjour
catherine talli alors christophe je vous
présente un peu nathalie non seulement
il est écrivain mais c'est d'un grand
spécialiste de théâtre il a été le cas
et s'est occupé de la librairie
théâtrale pendant pendant des années et
justement vous allez nous parler un
petit peu de terre du théâtre pendant
l'occupation
à travers un livre de pierre barillet
qui s'appelle quatre années sans relâche
et puis d'un livre qui vient de paraître
d'un grand écrivain italien qui
s'appelle erri de luca et qui s'appelle
impossible nathalie vous choisissez par
quoi vous voulez commencer et bien
commençons par le théâtre alors mai
théâtre et le théâtre sous l'occupation
gerda rayer la wii alors le monde du
spectacle comme vous le savez dans ces
périodes compliquées que notre action
est un peu en panne et j'ai beaucoup de
comédien metteur en scène directeur de
théâtre sur un peu dans le désarroi et
j'ai cherché un livre qui pourrait
montrer l'énergie des gens du spectacle
dans une période particulièrement sombre
et c'est un livre de pierre barillet qui
s'appelle quatre années sans relâche
voilà je vous le montre aux éditions de
fallois on peut toujours le le trouver
et le commander il s'agit de du théâtre
sous l'occupation à paris puisque vous
savez que aucun théâtre n'a fermé malgré
le couvre-feu et malgré les années
sombres qu'il passait alors on
s'aperçoit qu'on a une profusion de
création incroyable on va avoir à
nouilles avec le rang de senlis 141
10 toujours en 41 antigone en 42 le
voyageur sans bagage en 44 sarthe qui va
faire huit clos en 44 les mouches en
quarante trois laiteries qui va jouer
une écoute et pas mesdames pendant 600
représentations au théâtre de la
madeleine
montherlant avec la reine morte en 42 et
claudel le soulier de satin en 43 pour
ne parler que des que des grands mots de
l'iceberg
alors à l'intérieur de cette de cette
période sombre
on a des personnalités très fortes on va
avoir le couple cocteau-marais marais
qui va monter à la fois britannicus puis
andromaque il va voir un flop au alberto
avec la machine à écrire mais on va voir
des personnalités comme charles trenet
edith piaf charles trenet à qui on va
demander ces actes de baptême puisque
traîner on va dire que c'est agréable de
décréter juif un oui alors traîné l'un à
g donné terre donc considéré comme juif
parce que je suis partout donc il va
aller à narbonne demandé à sa maman de
retrouver tous les certificats et sa
maman va retrouver tous les certificats
depuis 1789 fois de calmer le jeu de la
gestapo
on va avoir d'autres personnalités
naturellement sacha guitry christian
bérard le peintre et décorateur
marie-laure de noailles qui va faire une
sorte dessin mondain dans son dans son
palais de la place des états unis et
puis il a tout et si non pardon ils vont
au printemps bien sûr alors ils veulent
printemps pierre fresnay naturellement
et et alors il va y avoir des ombres
alors les ombres c'est alain legros qui
faisait la vie et la mort d'une pièce
travers je suis partout qui étaient
souvent accompagnés de la milice pour
pouvoir fermer un théâtre qui
s'opposaient à edouard bourdais à jean
cocteau
il va y avoir lucien rebatet
naturellement toujours dans je suis
partout et qui vacille et ses chroniques
françois vineuil et puis des comédiennes
des comédiennes qui sont prêtes à tout
comme la comtesse solenska qui que l'on
croit chez maxime qui est ou dans les
boîtes de nuit dans les boîtes russes
notamment qui de son vrai nom s'appelle
irène blache et qui fera partie des
comtesses de la gestapo il ya corinne
luchaire la fille de jean luc certes il
sera fusillé à la libération jean du
cher et corinne luchaire qui l on
cherchera des petits rôles elle un très
beau physique une santé fragile elle va
avoir liaison avec un capitaine de la
louve bâton avec lequel elle aura une
fille brigitte et elle le sera frappée
de 10 ans d'indignité nationale
il est aussi alice cosea qui est au
théâtre que des ambassadeurs cinéma dans
les décors et les costumes cocteau de la
plaie la gravelotte
alors vous voyez tout ce jeu entre des
grandes personnalités des ombres
d'eiffage des lumières et puis une
profusion incroyable le texte de
création et de théâtre un état de son
plein pendant les quatre ans de
l'occupation ya une question quand même
qu'on se pose alors vous dites en effet
il ya ceux qui ont collaboré mais la
plupart c'est pas un thème de
collaboration jean marais était un
résistant par exemple donc donc c'est
pas un théâtre de collaboration ce qui
se fait oublier pacs il y en a et puis
mais il n'ya pas que ça un théâtre de
collaboration il va y avoir un théâtre
de de résistance mais il va y avoir
aussi un accommodement à cette période
d'ailleurs guy free va être arrêté vous
savez comme ça les deux fois au moment
de la libération et la même cette phrase
extraordinaire
paris libéré et je suis le premier
prévenu me laisse assez de guitry mais
marcel pagnol a été a été formidable
savait qu'il était président de l'esa
cédé au moment de l'épuration il va
faire un très beau travail parce qu'il
ya cette zone dont biassette zones de
lumière mais aussi cette zone grise et
cette zone grise est intéressante
vous savez que après les grandes
hier il y avait généralement un cocktail
à l'ambassade d'allemagne et alors là
des tas de relations se faisait et
pouvait aider d'autres projets à à
éclore
alors tout n'est pas rose tout n'est pas
noir il ya aussi cette telles crises
mais enfin tout le monde s'accommodait
et le théâtre fonctionner et il y avait
cette extraordinaire énergie encore une
fois les gens du spectacle qui avait
décidé que coûte que coûte il sortirait
de cette période fatigante et compliqué
et vous avez raison de le rappeler
aujourd'hui quatre années sans relâche
de pierre barillet c'est aux éditions de
fallois
vinciane qu'annick alors parlant d'olga
tôt car tu qu il ait réussi donc c'est
sur les ossements des morts c'est aux
éditions
dites moi d'ailleurs il va tout en fait
c'est un poche voilà c'est libretto qui
a réédité cette prix nobel de
littérature
moi j'ai cherché en fait des héros
monkey et vad
donc en fait finalement j'avais envie
d'un retour à la nature je pense que la
période s'y prête
donc en fait on part dans les sudètes
régions de pologne ou en fait finalement
c'est plus un récit c'est un conte pour
adultes où la nature va reprendre ses
droits sur une population qui les îles
et qui les méprise un peu qui sont des
chasseurs en fait et on suit en fait
laventure de la narratrice ni la douche
enhco tuez pas très doué non plus en
polonais qui habille ce petit village
isolé de pologne
elle vit pour les homes in man pour ses
renvois rendement elle ça on mélange
tout y mélanger un peu elle pas beaucoup
à l'astrologie à la force de la nature
retour d'anna nature c'est très
politique
enfin moi ça m'a emmené ça m'a emporté
loin loin de notre isolement
il ya un voyage nécessaires aujourd'hui
en période de confinement alors tous les
deux vinciane et et christophe vous avez
eu envie de parler de ce 2
livre impossible parution gallimard de
grands écrivains et ridé luca ça va être
intéressant d'avoir vous regarde
vinciane christophe christophe peut-être
commencé alors les rides et luca c'est
certainement un nobélisable c'est son
31e livre chez gallimard il avait publié
aussi au mercure de france et chez
seghers de la poésie erri de luca c'est
un homme qui est né à naples en 1950 et
qui a été ouvrier pendant 17 ans il est
assez autodidacte et il a un grand
grande passion pour la bible il avait
publié noyaux d'olives 26 réflexion sur
l'ancien et le nouveau testament chez
gallimard en 2004 et c'est une passion
il est la bible tous les jours il a
traduit d'ailleurs parce qu'il a appris
l'hébreu anciens et bien qu'un croyant
parce qu'il se dit un croyant voir à t
il à cette passion pour la beeb il a une
deuxième passion c'est pour la montagne
on l'avait lu à travers le poids du
papillon chez gallimard toujours en 2011
livre court mais dense il a parcouru le
népal l'himalaya et là on a en effet
l'histoire dans un possible c'est
l'histoire d'un homme qui aime la
montagne et qui part se promener en
montagne et vous savez comme quand on
marche en montagne il ya souvent
quelqu'un qui est devant vous quelqu'un
était derrière vous et alors on cherche
un peu à 100 là s'en affranchir
et quand quelqu'un est devant vous ou
cherchent plutôt à le doubler et là il
ya en effet un promeneur qui est devant
lui et puis il passe devant un passage
un peu un peu dangereux il ya une
crevasse et le la personne qui est
devant lui tombe dans la crevasse alors
ils appellent le 112 un hélicoptère
vient chercher le cadavre de cet homme
qui est cet homme
il se trouve que les deux hommes se
connaissent il se trouve que les deux
hommes ont été dans les années de plomb
italiennes ont été dans les brigades
rouges et que au moment de
des repentis et bien celui qui est mort
dans la crevasse et celui qui avait
dénoncé le narrateur qui fera de la tôle
à cause de ça vinciane l'ancienne avec
un succès sur ce livre et comment
peut-être la vie de vincennes cadic sur
ceux sur ses livres qu'elle voulait
aussi recommandé donc un bain
l'introduction est remarquablement menée
par monsieur maurice qui n'a rien
déflorer en fait du roman qui qui va en
fait
mélangez philosophie tout en étant
toujours au coeur de cette nature moi ce
palace était vraiment en sélectionnant
les niveaux je me suis rendu compte que
je n'avais lu que des livres avec
beaucoup de nature effectivement la
montagne quand même relativement
présente c'est tout petit c'est très
dense et ça ça sa force ça vraiment
réfléchir de réflexion hyper hyper
constructive et pareil ça emmène
ailleurs malgré en plus des vraies
questions aussi sur la politique sur sur
le droit sur sur la liberté
et puis l'amour est là même si la
formidable
nathalie le livre le livre est composé
ce qu'il faut on n'a plus qu'une minute
vous il le livre est composé de deux
types de narration il ya une par une
un dialogue qui re qui rappelle
l'interrogatoire de paget entre un flic
et lui et puis il ya une des lettres
d'amour à une femme sont totalement
bouleversant qui sont magnifiques et
très féminine d'une certaine façon ils
auraient et et surtout très enfin
totalement différente c'est presque un
récit un peu schizophrène quelque part
parce que on a vraiment deux faces du
personnage dans sa même moment et on
découvre un personnage à travers de
récits différents mais alors juste une
phrase à l'iran période de confinement
le temps de la réclusion ne me pèse pas
car même là dedans il reste le mien
c'est en plus un grand styliste en r&d
luca
malheureusement vinciane on n'a pas le
temps de parler de rentrer food de
colonial qui était aussi un roman sur
les animaux sur la chasse notamment
mais je vous propose d'en parler dans
une autre émission parce que c'est un
très joli roman un oui sans problème
avec plaisir et bien merci à tous les
deux merci christophe merci vinciane
merci patron merci nathalie et à très
vite pour un nouvel envies de lecture au
revoir
[Musique]